bonjour à tous
du désir de reconnaissance chez
on va rester dans la tête
sic du rapport à l'autre avec cette fois
ci un épisode sur sartre et le regard
des autres
le regard des autres est un sujet
extrêmement présent dans nos sociétés
contemporaines des sociétés de l'image
des sociétés de la représentation et il
semble qu'aucun d'entre nous ne soient à
l'abri du jugement des autres
or la philosophie de jean paul sartre
accorde une place très importante au
regard d'autrui
et d'ailleurs cette question se résume
dans l'une des citations les plus
célèbres de jean paul sartre l'enfer
c'est les autres
cette citation provient de la pièce de
théâtre huis clos et cette phrase a été
soumise à de très nombreuses
interprétations
l'interprétation la plus commune est
temps de dire que ce sont les autres qui
sont la cause de notre souffrance
une autre manière de dire que les gens
sont méchants et que le mal règne dans
le monde
alors est ce que c'est ça qu'a voulu
dire jean paul sartre à travers cette
phrase et bien non pas du tout
j'ai voulu dire l'enfer c'est les autres
mais l'enfer c'est les autres a été
toujours mal compris on a cru que je
voulais dire par là que nos rapports
avec les autres étaient toujours en
pause année le s'était toujours des
rapports internes
or c'est tout autre chose que je veux
dire je veux dire que si les rapports
avec autrui sont tordus vicié alors
l'autre ne peut être que l'enfer
pourquoi parce que les autres sont au
fond ce qui est plus important en
nous-mêmes pour notre propre
connaissance nous mêmes ce qui veut dire
que si mes rapports sont mauvais je me
mets dans la totale dépendance d'autrui
est alors en effet je suis en enfer et
il existe une quantité de gens dans le
monde qui sont en enfer parce qu'ils
dépendent 3 du jour
alors pour tenter d'expliciter cette
phrase on va explorer ensemble dans cet
épisode la question du regard des autres
la question du jugement d'autrui dans la
philosophie de jean paul sartre
alors avant d'entrer dans le vif du
sujet petit rappel sur sartre donc sa
retraite un philosophe existentialiste
plus exactement philosophe
existentialiste athée
et derrière le mot quelque peu effrayant
d'existentialisme se tient en fait une
conception du monde assez simple à
comprendre
l'existentialisme c'est la position
philosophique qui consiste à dire que
l'être humain n'a pas de nature
prédéterminé
prédéterminé autrement dit l'être humain
est fondamentalement libre
il est libre d'être ce qu'il choisit
d'être
l'existentialisme ça consiste à dire que
contrairement aux choses contrairement
aux objets inanimés
l'être humain n'est pas assigné n'est
pas réduit à une nature à une essence
qui lui seraient attribués de
l'extérieur
alors on va rentrer ça un petit peu plus
concret on va prendre un exemple qui est
l'exemple du téléphone
un téléphone c'est un objet qui a une
nature prédéterminé
le téléphone parce qu'il est le produit
d'une création humaine parce qu'il est
le produit d'une fabrication ayant un
but bien le téléphone il se définit par
sa fonction
le téléphone se définit comme un
appareil qui sert à communiquer à
distance avec des personnes possédant
cet objet
donc ce qui veut dire que le téléphone
avant d'exister matériellement avant
d'exister entre vos mains
il a d'abord été pensé il a d'abord été
conçu puis fabriqué et sa fabrication
est dirigée vers le seul et unique but
que le téléphone remplisse sa fonction
parce que fabriquer un téléphone qui ne
fonctionneraient pas qui ne rempliraient
pas sa fonction
ça n'aurait aucun sens
on connaît le destin des objets qui ne
remplissent plus leur fonction ils
finissent à la poubelle
raison d'être du téléphone c'est sa
fonction c'est de servir à téléphoner
ça paraît évident mais maintenant si on
pose la question à propos de l'être
humain et qu'on se demande quelle est la
raison d'être de l'être humain quelle
est sa fonction
qu'est ce qui justifie son existence
bien là on est embarrassé
on est embarrassé par ce que nous
n'existons pas pour les mêmes raisons
et pour sartre c'est même encore pire
que ça en pour sartre l'homme n'a aucune
raison d'exister
une raison d'exister tout simplement
parce qu'il n'est pas le produit d'une
conception
l'être humain n'a pas de raison d'être
parce qu'il n'est pas le résultat d'un
projet un projet qui aurait une finalité
et c'est là qu'on voit que l'athéisme de
sartre est un élément essentiel de sa
philosophie
parce que dans une vision théistes de
l'univers une vision dans laquelle les
hommes ont été créés par dieu et à ce
moment là on peut dire que l'existence
humaine a un sens un sens prédéfinis un
sens prédéterminé par dieu
et dans ce cas là il devient possible de
dire que la fonction de l'être humain
c'est de réaliser la volonté divine
mais sartre lui ne s'inscrit absolument
pas dans ce système de pensée pour
sartre il n'ya pas de dieu dans
l'univers
il n'y a pas de créateurs des êtres
humains ce qui veut dire que le sens de
notre existence
c'est nous qui allons le construire il
n'ya pas de dieu pour nous indiquer la
direction il n'y a pas de sens pré
établi à nos existences individuelles et
c'est ce qui fait que chacun va tenter
comme il le peut de donner un sens à sa
présence sur terre
sartre établi une distinction très nette
entre le règne des choses et le règne
des personnes et personnes sont libres
les personnes n'ont pas de nature
prédéfinis
on pourrait dire que la seule nature des
hommes c'est de construire eux-mêmes
leur propre nature
et donc l'existentialisme ça consiste
tout simplement à dire que pour les
êtres humains
l'existence précède l'essence
l'existence précède l'essence autrement
dit nous existons et nous construisons
notre essence
al'inverse des choses qui elles sont
d'abord conçus par rapport à leur
fonction par rapport à leur essence et
qui ensuite sont fabriqués c'est à dire
sont amenés à exister
l'existentialisme c'est la doctrine
philosophique qui consiste à dire que
l'être humain n'est prédéterminé par
aucune autre essence que celle qu'il
réalise à travers ses actes
et donc ça ça nous conduit à un nouveau
concept de la philosophie sartrienne qui
est le concept de subjectivité
pour sartre l'être humain est d'abord
une subjectivité
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une subjectivité
et bien c'est tout simplement un point
de vue sur le monde
une chose n'a pas de point de vue sur le
monde tout simplement parce qu'elle n'a
pas de capacité de perception
et a fortiori elle n'a pas de conscience
l'être humain possède une conscience
l'être humain est capable de percevoir
le monde autour de lui et donc la marque
caractéristique de la condition humaine
c'est le fait d'être en interaction
permanente avec le monde
l'individu humain l'individu conscient
est toujours impliqué dans des relations
avec le monde
avec le monde et avec autrui c'est à
dire avec d'autres consciences
donc ce qui fait la particularité de la
condition humaine
c'est son rapport particulier au monde
qui l'entourent
le mode d'être de l'individu humain
c'est ce que heidegger a appelé l'être
au monde l'être au monde c'est à dire
lettres en rapport avec le monde
tandis que le mode d'être de la chose
c'est ce que heidegger appelé l'être
dans le monde
chose et dans le monde mais elle n'est
pas en interaction avec le monde dans la
mesure où elle ne peut pas échanger avec
lui
chose peut être un support des changes
entre les êtres humains on peut
s'échanger des objets on peut discuter à
propos des objets mais on peut pas
échanger ou discuter avec un objet
si vous préférez une chose se moque
totalement de nous
chose est indifférente à non
alors que nous autres êtres humains nous
ne sommes pas indifférents à ce que nous
sommes les uns pour les autres
et nous ne sommes pas non plus
indifférent à ce que nous sommes pour
nous mêmes
en tant qu êtres dotés d'une conscience
nous sommes en mesure de nous
questionner sur nous mêmes
2 nous examiner nous mêmes
de nous juger nous mêmes
fait dire à sartre que seuls les êtres
humains seuls les individus conscients
sont dotés d'une existence
puisque pour lui l'existence ce n'est
pas seulement lettre ces lettres en
conscience
ces lettres en interaction avec le monde
donc je n'existe pas comme existe une
chose je n'existe pas comme existe une
table un vélo ou une paire de lunettes
j'existe comme conscience c'est-à-dire
comme point de vue sur le monde
j'existe comme regard
et quand je parlais de la distinction
heideggerienne entre l'être au monde et
lettres dans le monde
on pourrait même aller encore plus loin
à savoir que si je ne suis pas seulement
dans le monde c'est parce que je suis le
monde
je suis le monde que je perçois
je suis le monde que ma conscience fait
exister
et dire que je suis le monde ça n'a rien
d'une position mégalomaniaque
ça ne veut pas dire que je suis le seul
à exister dans le monde
mais ça veut dire que pour moi à mon
échelle le monde
c'est ma conscience du monde
c'est ma perception du monde c'est mon
expérience du monde
et vous pourrez retourner le problème
dans tous les sens possibles le fait est
qu'à l'arrivée le seul monde que vous
aurez expérimenté c'est le monde que
vous aurez perçu
film de votre vie c'est le film de votre
perception de votre vie
et donc si on applique le même
raisonnement à tous les êtres conscients
et bien on peut dire que chaque
conscience est un monde à part entière
puisque chaque conscience possède son
propre point de vue sur le monde
chaque conscience est un monde à part
entière et ses mondes s'entrecroisent et
s'interpénètrent à l'occasion d'un
phénomène que nous expérimentons tous
quotidiennement la rencontre
la rencontre avec autrui c'est la
rencontre avec une autre conscience
c'est la rencontre avec une autre
subjectivité
la rencontre avec autrui c'est la
rencontre entre deux mondes et ça selon
sartre c'est ce qui va totalement
bouleversé ma représentation de ma
condition
que se passe-t-il lorsque j'entre en
interaction avec autrui
interagit avec autrui il se produit un
phénomène très particulier qui est que
je ne suis plus seulement une conscience
qui perçoit le monde
je deviens l'objet d'une conscience
autre que la mienne
extérieur
et d'expliquer sa de la manière la plus
simple qui soit
sinon que vous vous baladez dans un parc
et un moment donné au loin vous
apercevez quelqu'un
quelqu'un qui marche dans votre
direction
à ce moment là qu'est ce qui va se
passer bien il va se passer que vous
allez prendre conscience que vous n'êtes
plus seuls
parce que dans votre monde surgit un
nouvel élément
et cet élément n'est pas n'importe
lequel puisqu'il s'agit d'une autre
conscience
et maintenant imaginons que vous vous
rapprochez de cette personne en même
temps qu'elle se rapproche de vous et
que vos regards se croisent
eh bien au moment où vos regards se
croisent vous savez que vous êtes l'un
pour l'autre un élément de vaud mondes
respectifs
ce qui veut dire qu'en même temps que
vous voyez l'autre vous prenez
conscience que vous êtes en même temps
vu par l'autre
et être vu par l'autre ça veut dire que
ce n'est plus votre conscience qui règne
lorsque l'autre surgi devant moi je fais
l'expérience du décentrage de mon monde
ne suis plus le centre du monde je
deviens un élément du monde dont la
conscience de l'autre et le centre
et à partir du moment où vous
apparaissez comme un objet pour une
autre conscience vous cesser d'exister
comme subjectivité
vous cesser d'exister comme conscience
souveraine
à partir du moment où vous vous
retrouvez dans le champ de perception
d'autrui
vous n'êtes plus une conscience
vous êtes l'objet d'une conscience vous
devenez une conscience a servi à la
conscience d'autrui
dans le regard de l'autre je ne
suis plus une conscience
je suis un élément de son décor
suit un élément de sa conscience
ainsi le regard de l'autre et comme un
enlèvement le regard de l'autre c'est à
la ping
par le simple fait qu'il me regarde
l'autre mme extra de mon monde pour me
placer dans son monde
pour faire de moi un élément de sa
subjectivité
ce sens tout regard fait de moi une
chose
pour regard est une réification tout
regard est une objectivation
tout regard est une réduction de ma
conscience au statut d'objet pour une
autre conscience
alors je sais que ça peut paraître
étrange de considérer les choses de
cette manière là mais si vous êtes
attentifs à ce qui se passe dans votre
interaction avec autrui
vous allez voir que ce que je viens
d'écrire n'est pas du tout aberrant
évidemment quand vous croiser le regard
de quelqu'un vous n'allez pas vous dire
tout ça explicitement
vous pourrez vous dire qu'effectivement
à ce moment là vous êtes l'objet d'une
perception
vous êtes vu du dehors
être vu du dehors c'est être vu comme
une chose
parce que rappelez vous que la seule
partie de vous même à laquelle vous
n'avez pas accès c'est votre dehors
c'est votre extériorité
vous habitez votre corps vous êtes donc
en contact permanent avec votre
intériorité mais votre enveloppe
corporelle et en particulier votre
visage
vos yeux
tout ça ça ne vous est pas accessible
drame de l'altérité c'est que sous un
certain aspect l'autre me connais mieux
que je ne me connais moi-même
nous sommes les seuls à ne pas nous
connaître de l'extérieur
et c'est pourquoi se voir en vidéo ou
entendre sa voix ça provoque toujours
une sensation étrange
la sensation que ce n'est pas nous
c'est pour ça qu'on peut dire que sous
le regard d'autrui la situation nous
échappe
aso nous échappe puisque l'autre dispose
d'un point de vue sur nous mêmes que
nous n'avons pas à nous mêmes ce qui est
quand même le comble de l'ironie
on se regarde dans un miroir on sait que
c'est nous mais on ne se reconnaît pas y
at il quelqu'un qui m'est plus étranger
que cette personne que je perçois dans
le miroir
alors oui je me reconnais
superficiellement je reconnais les
traits de mon visage je reconnais ma
morphologie mais dès lors que je me fixe
dans les yeux je cesse de me reconnaître
alors je deviens celui qui me regardent
c'est à ce moment là que je comprend ce
qui se passe dans ce déplacement de
l'être pour soi à lettres pour autrui
pour autrui c'est à dire ce que je suis
pour les autres
et pour l'autre je suis un objet
quand je croise le regard de l'autre je
vois que je suis vue
je me vois vue
et voyez cette juxtaposition de la voix
active et de la voix passive voir et
être vu c'est ce qui décrit le mieux le
mécanisme de mon rapport au monde
une conscience active je suis mon propre
monde un monde dans lequel peuvent
apparaître d'autres individus qui seront
les objets de ma conscience
mais je suis également et en même temps
l'individu qui apparaît dans le monde
d'autrui
et c'est ce qui fait dire à sartre que
dans la rencontre avec l'autre dans le
regard de l'autre je fais l'expérience
de la réunification
je deviens une simple chose
et donc mon réflexe métaphysique premier
ça va être de me soustraire aux yeux
d'autrui
car autrui fait peser sur moi une
pression d'être
qu'est ce que c'est une pression d'être
et bien c'est tout simplement le désir
d'apparaître d'une certaine manière aux
yeux de l'autre
c'est ce qui fait par exemple que quand
vous allez croiser quelqu'un dans la rue
vous allez vous redressez vous allez
rendre votre démarche plus assurée
vous allez vouloir maîtriser votre image
aux yeux d'autrui
vous allez vouloir maîtriser l'objet que
vous êtes pour la conscience de l'autre
le regard de l'autre est toujours une
pression exercée sur notre conscience
parce que dès lors qu'un regard se pose
sur nous nous sommes en représentation
or dans l'un de ses romans la nausée
sartre nous parle d'un personnage
monsieur fasquelle en écrivant à son
propos quand cet homme est seul il
s'endort
et quand est-ce qu'on s'endort quand on
est fatigués certes mais aussi quand on
est apaisé
quand on est tranquilliser
le regard de l'autre me met dans un état
de non tranquillité
d'inquiétude 2
et c'est pour ça que lorsque sartre
décrit notre relation à autrui
il évoque en termes de surgissement
l'autre c'est celui qui surgit dans mon
monde
pourquoi les gens timides baisse-t-il
les yeux devant les autres
parce qu'ils ne veulent pas rencontrer
le regard qu'ils les examinent comme des
objets
se passe-t-il lorsque quelqu'un vous
dévisage
si d'air comme un objet
il vous considère comme impurs dehors
comme une pure extériorité dans sa
conscience pourrait disposer librement
et la gêne la honte ou la timidité
traduisent le trouble de la conscience
qui sait qu'elle est jugée par une autre
conscience
car dès lors qu'elle est jugée la
conscience cesse d'être une conscience
elle n'est plus considérée comme une
conscience
elle est considérée comme un simple
objet
objet de quoi l'objet du jugement
et en baissant les yeux bandés
dans le regard la personne timide créer
l'illusion de ne plus être observés
comme en fermant les yeux on se donne
l'impression que l'autre ne nous voit
plus
mais en réalité on le fait qu'il y
aurait le spectacle du jugement de
l'autre sur nous mêmes
si ça va être le moment d'entrer dans le
détail de ce processus de réification
qui s'opèrent dans le regard d'autrui
ça va être le moment d'expliquer en quoi
le regard d'autrui me fige
et ainsi
je d'exister
et que la conscience de soi était en
réalité une conscience indirecte de soi
être conscient de soi c'est adopter
temporairement le point de vue d'une
conscience extérieur à soi
autrement dit être conscient de soi
c'est se prendre comme objet de sa
propre conscience
il ya donc dans la conscience de soi un
phénomène de dissociation
nous sommes à la fois sujet et objet de
notre perception
qu'à chaque fois que je me considère à
chaque fois que je me juge c'est
toujours à partir du point de vue
d'autrui
d'autrui n'est que virtuelle
même si cet autrui n'est pas
physiquement là devant moi mais il
n'empêche que je me projette dans un
autrui virtuelle à partir duquel je vais
me considérer
c'est ce qui fait dire à sartre que
l'autre est un médiateur entre moi et
moi
et qu'est ce que nous gagnons en ou
transposant dans la conscience d'autrui
en opérant ce décentrage de nous mêmes
eh bien nous gagnons l'accès à une
dimension de nous qui nous échappe
ses dimensions c'est notre extériorité
le regard est le lieu du jugement car le
regard est le lieu d'une observation
extérieur qui ne peut que réduire notre
être fondamental
et notre être fondamental qu'est ce que
c'est c'est notre subjectivité par
laquelle nous sommes des êtres libres
c'est notre conscience ou si vous
préférez notre monde intérieur celui
auquel je suis seul à avoir accès
et que l'autre parce qu'il est à
lui-même sa propre subjectivité ne peut
que nier
l'autre ne peut que meunier en tant que
conscience
on le disait en préambule de cet épisode
l'essence de l'homme c'est de ne pas
avoir d'essence
sens de l'homme c'est le néant
dans son livre l'être et le néant sartre
considère que l'homme se tient du côté
du néant
l'homme est né en car l'homme et
possibilités
l'homme et potentialités
si l'homme n'est rien c'est parce qu'il
est potentiellement tous
or l'être c'est le contraire de la
liberté
l'être c'est l'attribution
c'est la fixation
c'est l'assignation à une essence
invariante
sartre prend l'exemple du coupe papier
il dit bien que le coupe-papier est
condamné à n'être qu'un coupe papier
il ne peut pas être autre chose
al'inverse l'homme est condamné à être
libre
il est condamné à être ce qu'il choisira
d'être
c'est ça l'irréductibilité de la liberté
humaine
l'un possibilité d'assigner à l'être
humain une essence
l'impossibilité de figer l'être humain
dans une essence
or que fait autrui quand ils me
regardent ils me fige dans une essence
et qu'est ce que ça veut dire de dire
que l'autre me fige dans une essence et
bien ça veut dire que parce que je suis
l'objet de sa conscience
je ne suis plus une conscience pour lui
je ne suis qu'une représentation
je ne suis qu'un avatar une image
je ne suis qu'un pur dehors
une pure extériorité vidé de sa
substance qui est sa conscience
c'est ça qui se produit dans le regard
d'autrui la négation de ma substance
et même si l'autre apprend à me
connaître si l'autre apprend à me
connaître de manière intime intime c'est
à dire intérieur je reste malgré tout
fondamentalement irréductible à la
représentation qui se fera de moi
regard d'autrui c'est le regard qui me
fige dans une essence à laquelle je suis
et réductible
une essence qui quelle qu'elle soit sera
toujours trop étriqué pour ma conscience
sera toujours une dénaturation de ce que
je suis
ce sera toujours une trahison de ce que
pour illustrer cette idée on va faire
une petite expérience je vais vous
demander de penser à une personne que
vous connaissez
un de vos proches un ami ou un collègue
de travail
maintenant essayer de vous représenter
cette personne visuellement donc là vous
pouvez la voir pouvez voir les traits de
son visage
la couleur de ses cheveux la forme de
son nez de sa bouche
vous avez un point de vue extérieur sur
elle
maintenant je vais vous demander de
penser à ce qui la caractérise
psychologiquement
à son tempérament à sa manière d'être à
ces réactions dans telle ou telle
circonstance
à partir de là je vous demander d'aller
encore un peu plus loin je vais vous
demander d'imaginer que vous êtes à sa
place
imaginez que vous êtes cette personne
imaginez que vous vous trouvez plonger
dans sa conscience vous voyez désormais
le monde à travers ses yeux
ma question est la suivante
et vous maintenant à quoi pensez-vous
maintenant que vit votre
là maintenant
vous n'en savez rien
vous ne saviez
vous est impossible de vivre à travers
la conscience d'autrui
houdan savait rien parce qu'il vous est
impossible de vous approprier la
conscience d'autrui
la conscience d'autrui que vous échappe
fondamentalement et c'est cette
impossibilité de vous transplanté dans
la conscience d'autrui qui explique
l'écart fondamentale et irréductible
qu'il y aura toujours entre votre
conscience et la conscience d'autrui
la conscience d'autrui est un donjon
imprenable
à chaque fois vous allez regarder
l'autre à chaque fois que vous allez
juger l'autre ce n'est pas l'autre que
vous jugez
votre représentation de ce qu'est
l'autre
comprendre et saisir cette conscience
qui est en face de vous il faudrait que
l'autre ne soit plus l'objet de votre
conscience
mais le sujet de votre conscience
pour saisir l'autre il faudrait que vous
soyez l'autre
donc à la question que vit cette
conscience qui se tient là devant moi la
réponse est je n'en sais rien
vous connaissez la personne si vous êtes
capable de deviner ses pensées aux ses
sentiments le fait est que vous ne
pouvez pas aller au-delà de ce dehors
qui se présentent à vous
la réalité c'est que nous sommes
incapables de saisir l'autre dans tous
les mouvements de sa conscience
autrui me juge en permanence et en meuse
gens ils se méprend sur mon compte
il
mais prend parce qu'il ne peut que se
méprendre
autrui c'est la conscience sur laquelle
je n'ai pas de contrôle
c'est la conscience à laquelle il m'est
impossible d'avoir accès
et vous connaissez cette célèbre
question qu'on vous a tous déjà posé en
moins une fois le fameux à quoi tu
penses
à quoi je pense
savoir à quoi je pense mais cette
question
même à quoi tu penses est révélatrice
elle est révélatrice de notre tendance
inconsciente à vouloir nous approprier
la conscience d'autrui
trouve sa tendance dans d'autres phrases
de la vie quotidienne comme par exemple
lorsqu'on dit qu'on n'arrive pas à
cerner quelqu'un
lui je n'arrive pas à le cerner
tu ne pourras jamais cerner l'autre
pas toujours le jugement c'est la
tendance nature
de l'être humain à figer l'autre dans
une essence pour le rendre identifiables
si le jugement est toujours une
réification c'est parce que le regard de
l'autre me pétrifie
sens littéral
il me transforme en pierre il me
mobilise
et ainsi il me déshumanise
le regard de l'autre me pétrifie il me
transforme en statue en une
représentation fixe de ma personne
c'est bien ça qu'indique le mot statut
l'idée d'une fixation la statue c'est ce
qui est statique
de la même façon qu'une photo est un
instantané
un instantané qui cherche à me
stabiliser
voyez tous ces mots avec cette suite de
consonnes st qu'indique la fixation
qu'indique la territorialisation
on veut fixer l'autre on veut l'ancré
dans une essence
c'est ça la réification la conscience de
l'autre c'est le désir d'identifier
l'autre en le fixant dans une
représentation
pour ainsi pouvoir en faire un élément
notre décor et l'inclure dans notre
cartographie
mais il est fondamentalement vain de
vouloir figer l'autre dans une essence
parce que la conscience de l'autre n'est
jamais figé
elle est toujours en mouvement
elle est toujours en train d'advenir
elle est toujours fluide
c'est exactement ce qui se produit en
physique quantique à savoir que
l'observation fige le corps observée
dans une position
l'idée étant qu'on ne peut pas mesurer
le corps semble avoir figé mais que dès
lors qu'on le fige on le dénature
mesurée du mouvement avec du statique
c'est exactement ce que bergson reproche
à l'esprit humain
ce besoin de catégoriser ce besoin de
compartimenter
besoin de stopper le mouvement pour
prétendre restituer le mouvement
sauf que robertson on ne restitue pas du
mouvement en le filon
on ne saisit pas un mouvement en niant
son caractère mouvant
et donc à chaque fois que je cherche à
définir l'autre à chaque fois que je
cherche à l'identifier à me représenter
je fais de l'autre un objet et ce
faisant je le dénature
l'homme n'a pas de nature
c'est l'autre qui nous donne une nature
lorsque l'autre nous jugent ils nous
essentialise
il nous donne une essence
l'autre me fait être parce que l'autre a
besoin que je sois pour pouvoir me juger
et d'ailleurs observer la déception qui
est la nôtre quand l'autre ne se
conforment plus à l'image qu'on s'en
était forgé
quand l'autre ne se comporte plus de la
manière dont on attendait qu'il se
comporte
quand l'autre exprime quelque chose qui
sort du cadre de ce que nous avions
projeté sur lui
qu'est ce qu'on dira à ce moment là
trompée sur lui
oui tu t'es trompé bien sûr
tu t'es trompé à l'assaut
tu l'a jugée tu t'es trompé car l'erreur
ce n'est pas de l'avoir mal jugé
l'erreur c'est de l'avoir jugé tout
court
l'autre c'est celui qui ne me connaît
pas c'est celui qui est dans
l'impossibilité fondamentale de savoir
ce que je suis
et en même temps c'est celui qui me
jugent ou c'est celui qui m'a vente
et quand on veut savoir ce que pense
l'autre on veut savoir en particulier ce
qu'ils pensent de nous on veut savoir
quelle image de nous il a créé
quel objet nous sommes pour sa
conscience
on va se poser tout un tas de questions
que ce deal autres quand ils me voient
que pense-t-il de moi
que fait-il de moi
peuvent-ils deux mois dans sa conscience
ainsi on veut maîtriser le jugement
d'autrui sur nous mêmes parce qu'on veut
maîtriser la part de nous-mêmes que
l'autre extrade dans sa conscience
et se demander comment l'autre me vois
c'est vouloir maîtriser le jugement
d'autrui sur nous mêmes
ses désirs et maîtriser ce que l'autre
fait de nous dans sa conscience
comme une sorte de droit de propriété
sur notre être sur lequel on va avoir un
droit de regard
littéralement
ce qui fait qu'on déteste que les autres
se trompent sur nous
on déteste que les autres nous assigne à
une identité dans laquelle nous ne nous
reconnaissons pas
mais remarquez bien de choses
c'est que si on refuse que les autres
nous assigne à une identité qui n'est
pas la nôtre c'est parce qu'on s'assigne
soi-même constamment à une autre
identité
comment dit on refuse que l'autre nous
fige mais nous mêmes nous nous figeons
en permanence
soit
fini on se
caractérise
sa tribu les qualités et défauts on dira
par exemple je suis quelqu'un de
sensible où je suis quelqu'un de franc
où je suis quelqu'un de compréhensifs
on dira je suis pour ceux ci et contre
cela
bref on va faire l'inventaire de nos
caractéristiques
va répertorier nos qualités et nos
défauts pour rectifier le faux jugement
d'autrui sur soi et pour le remplacer
par notre jugement sur soi
mais en faisant ça est-ce qu on rétablit
la vérité sur nous mêmes
pour sartre la réponse est claire
non
la vérité sur nous-mêmes en remplaçant
le jugement d'autrui par notre propre
jugement
parce qu'alors on reste dans la logique
du jugement on reste donc dans la
logique de la réunification
il pas la vérité sur nous-mêmes en
remplaçant une fixation par une autre
fixation ont rétabli la vérité sur nous
mêmes en faisant sauter toutes les
fixations
c'est ça la vérité fondamentale de
l'être humain
ça ça nous gêne
ça nous gêne parce que sans fixation
sans assignation
sommes perdus on a besoin d'eux
pères on a besoin
voir définir notre identité parce que si
rien ne nous définit plus ça signifie
que nous ne sommes plus rien
c'est pour ça qu'on aime dire ce qu'on
est qu'on aime dire ce qu'on pense qu'on
aime dire ce qu'on veut pour être
reconnaissable et identifiable
aux yeux des autres
et ce faisant on participe activement à
notre propre griffe ication
fait le complice
propre asservissement
à travers le
non
m'oblige à être alors que ma nature
ce n'est pas d'être c'est d'exister
voir qui je suis parce que moi même
j'ignore qui je suis
j'ignore qui je suive parce que je ne
suis pas
euh je ne suis rien pour sartre nous
me rien
parce que nous existons
exister ce n'est pas être
existé s'est renversée lettres en
permanence
c'est renverser toutes les définitions
toutes les étiquettes toutes les
assignations
être c'est se définir
c'est s'auto incarcéré
exister c'est vivre l'aventuré de la
liberté humaine
la tendance
qu'elle nous nous assignons nous mêmes
des caractéristiques qui nous
définissent qui définissent notre être
qui définissent notre identité sartre
l'appelle la mauvaise foi
la mauvaise foi c'est la participation à
la négation de notre liberté
fondamentale en tant que conscience
créatrice
en tant que conscience plongez dans
l'existence
c'est ce qui fait qu'au quotidien nous
n'existons pas
nous jouons à exister
et d'ailleurs petite remarque
grammaticales intéressante
être c'est un verbe qui admet un
attribut on est quelque chose
alors qu'existaient c'est ce qu'on
appelle un verbe intransitif c'est un
verbe derrière lequel on ne peut mettre
aucun complément
on n'existe pas quelque chose on
n'existe point
c'est un absolu être ses devoirs être
sait faire primer la logique du surmoi
gic de l'hymne authenticité
de ce que sartre rappelle la facticité
face à l'autre nous n'existons pas nous
jouons
lorsqu'on dit je suis comme ça c'est ma
nature
et si c'est la nature je ne peux pas la
changer
comme ça c'est de la mauvaise foi
se définir se donner un rôle c'est
s'obliger à correspondre à soi c'est un
fardeau pour illustrer son concept de
mauvaise foi sartre prend l'exemple du
garçon de café aux garçons de café c'est
celui qui joue à être garçons de café
au point de se convaincre qu'il est un
garçon de café
fille quand il rentre chez lui après le
service
le garçon de café jouera à être mari
et jouera à être père
à à tout ce qu'il voudra du moment qu'il
endossera un rôle
on peut sortir d'un rôle mais on ne sort
jamais du rôle
c'est la rolls à un autre
et passe
jouant un rôle parce que nous jouons des
rôles nous sommes en perpétuelle
représentation
représentations à soi représentation aux
autres
tel est le parrain
hawx de la condition humaine que nous ne
croyons jamais autant existait que
lorsque nous jouons à être
il est heroes
qu'un des philosophes ayant le plus
afficher son athéisme soit
principalement connu pour une phrase
dans laquelle il évoque l' enfer
l'enfer c'est le prix de la culpabilité
et on a eu l'occasion de parler dans un
autre épisode de la faute d'adam et eve
une faute qui les a conduits à
expérimenter directement les lois de la
matière
les lois de la souffrance et du temps
les lois de la culpabilité
mythologie égyptienne la pesée des
coeurs on pourrait assimiler à la pesée
des âmes
c'est l'examen de conscience du défunt
au cours duquel on évalue le poids de sa
culpabilité
si le coeur du défunt et plus léger que
la plume de maths en accorde au défunt
le statut de bienheureux
on lui donne l'accès à la vie éternelle
et si son coeur pèse plus lourd que
cette plume
le défunt est engloutie par le monstre à
mouthe
la grande dévoreuse
maintenant supposer que l'enfer c'est la
mauvaise conscience
c'est la conscience lourde
hazim c'est la bonne conscience
c'est l'âme légère
emprise du jugement d'autrui mme
à chaque fois que nous soumettons au
procès que l'autre nous livre en
permanence
comme en enfer
à chaque fois que je mets mon sip du
regard d'autrui
à chaque fois que je choisis mme
laliberté de l'existence au lieu de la
pétrification de lettres du rôle de
l'image
j'accède au paradis
être sommes nous en enfer à l'heure où
je parle
l'enfer n'est-il que l'autre nom du
poids de notre conscience aliénés
notre enfermement dans le monde la
représentation
notre peur
nous les créateurs de notre enfer sur
terre
ce monde de ténèbres de souffrance
qu on ne détruit pas en le combattant
mais en l'inondant de notre lumière je
vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]